[Music]
this is just a super quick video about
global event 5 blackout that will be
dropping shortly after the one point 8.1
is released on the 12th of April most of
the information here is based on the
recent pts so there is the possibility
that there has been a few changes
implemented since firstly I don't really
know why it's called blackout naturally
when I first heard about it I assumed it
would be something to do with the ingame
lighting similar to what the Reddit user
could death to could get death so cat if
so CAD posted a little while before the
new patch was announced lights out dark
dangerous so for the remainder of this
video I'm gonna swap out the word
blackout for Pikachu as I feel this is a
better representation the global
modifier Pikachu will be active at all
times during the event regardless of
what PvE content you're playing agents
are equipped with shock ammo that stuns
enemies shooting or running builds your
charge meter the more charge the more
damage you inflict based on the pts this
is quite a lot of fun similar to the
assault global modifier it just makes
you feel really powerful you aren't
doing as much damage as an assault but
and this you don't have to worry about
range I'm expecting some pretty good
speedruns coming out of this event the
activity modifier extreme Pikachu can
only be activated when playing through
the missions and content that are
included in the global event playlist
Pikachu behavior plus you can instantly
kill enemies with over charged melee
attacks but if you miss or you mix out
your charge meter you'll stun yourself
and your allies this basically means
that you'll fill up your charge meter by
running and shooting the same as the
global modifier except if you keep going
after your bar is full you'll get
shocked very similar to the way that
shock ammo directive works in
underground the electro-charged melee
attacks can be pretty fun though the
group modifier total Pikachu includes
both the global and group modifiers but
it gives a bit of assistance and keeping
your charge meter down extreme Pikachu
behavior plus your charge meter will
cool down faster when close to other
group members Pikachu loves cuddles
the missions included in the global
event roster are Times Square power
relay Hudson refugee camp general
assembly Lincoln Tunnel checkpoint and
the incursion is Falcons lost
again based on the pts the classified
gear available during this global event
is d3 if NC Dead Eye strikers and
technicians Authority this is also to be
the first global event to allow us to
buy caches specific to each of the
classified sits above not sure of the GE
credit cost of these yet and the pts
they were all free it's likely that if
you are starting from scratch with
collecting these sets that the superior
cache would be the most cost efficient
but when you're down to just your last
one or two pieces that you need the more
specific caches although more expensive
will give you a greater chance of
acquiring the missing pieces with the
global modifier and blackhat Pikachu
just run whatever build you feel
comfortable with as long as you're
running around and shooting this
modifier will only have you doing more
damage but when it comes to the activity
and group modifiers you may want to run
something with a little more
sustainability like nomads or strikers
getting shocked will leave you
vulnerable for a short period of time
probably the biggest tip I can give you
for this global event with these
modifiers is to run an immunizes support
station while standing in the immunize
er you don't have to worry about
shocking yourself when maxing out your
charge meter plus your teammates will be
happy because every time you get shocked
they do too this makes these modifiers a
lot more bearable having to polish your
weapon and worry about your meter really
slows things down and very quickly takes
the fun out of it overall this global
event is pretty fun to play through
there are a ton of new commendations too
but I'm not going to go over any of them
because I'm expecting a little bit of
change here a lot we're based on things
like the leaderboard of which I'm really
hoping they've learned a lesson here
rewards based on a leaderboard will
always lead to increased hacking or
abuse of game mechanics just quickly
before I go the request I put out in the
last video around getting a crew
together to team up on PC was received a
lot better than I was expecting
tons of emails comments and messages on
Twitter
I haven't replied to everyone yet but
I'm getting through them I wasn't really
expecting so many people to be keen so
in order to everyone Justice of asked
for some help from a mate wanderer to
set up a discord channel for the
community I think he's pretty much done
his part he just has to run me through
it I haven't really used discord too
much
so got to make sure I don't just break
it straight away so if I can get some
time I really hope to be able to give a
link out in the next few days otherwise
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next one
Cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]